unser top thema heute maske runter im
flugzeug maske auf in bus und bahn wie
stimmig ist das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz kommen wir mit
den umweg von impfstoffen sicher durch
den winter das top thema jetzt im zdf
morgenmagazin
viel zu besprechen also mit
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach der
gleich bei uns im studio ist ja und so
fort berichtet natalie wollmann über das
neue infektionsschutzgesetz aber auch
über die kritik daran
protest gegen das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz im sankt
elisabeth in erfurt ab herbst müssen sie
im altenpflegeheim wieder eine fb2 maske
tragen
belastend eigentlich schön ist es nicht
also geht man möglichst auch nicht
dorthin wo solche dinge gefordert sind
darüber hinaus geht in
pflegeeinrichtungen eine corona
testpflicht
einlasskontrolle zertifikats check und
dokumentation ist dann wieder aufgabe
der pfleger es bleibt bei einer hohen
belastung für die mitarbeitenden in den
pflegeeinrichtungen
es versteht kein mensch denn bei
konzerten fußballstadien da findet quasi
die pandemie nicht mehr statt aber in
unseren pflegeeinrichtungen werden
maßnahmen verhandeln als wende stand in
der pandemie haben nach wochenlangen
gezerre steht der kompromiss heute soll
der bundestag beschließen
zum ersten oktober kommen dann die neuen
core ohne regeln die fdp hat dem
gesetzesentwurf vorgestern den letzten
feinschliff verpasst keine maske mehr im
flieger die lufthansa hatte darauf
gedrängt den fernverkehr der bahn
dagegen bleibt die maske pflicht man
merkte in dieser koalition mit verlaub
das fdp jedes mal nach steuert und der
bundesgesundheitsminister eine ganz
andere meinung hat sich aber nicht mehr
durchsetzen kann aber den menschen jeden
tag eine neue ansage zu machen und denen
in der bahn zu sagen für euch gilt die
maske noch im flugzeug aber vielleicht
nicht mehr da verlieren wir tatsächlich
vertrauen
ab herbst wird es zudem unübersichtlich
es gibt kaum weitere bundeseinheitliche
regeln so entscheiden beim nahverkehr
die länder auf maske oder nicht es droht
ein flickenteppich diese jetzige
regelung fast nirgends mehr maske tragen
zu müssen nur noch im fernverkehr der
deutschen bahn ist nicht erklärbar nicht
nachvollziehbar
deshalb muss die politik sich
entscheiden entweder masken pflicht in
allen verkehrsmitteln oder in keinem
gleiches recht für alle das finden sie
auch hier sie wollen bei sich zu hause
keine maske tragen eben genauso wie alle
grund bundesgesundheitsminister carlotta
war vor der spd ist zu uns gekommen ist
denn guten morgen herr lauterbach wir
haben gerade die pflegeheime gesehen da
gibt es auch kritik und auch ein
bisschen unverständnis das jetzt zum
beispiel so strengere maßnahmen im
pflegeheim gelten aber in fußballstadien
eigentlich gar keine maßnahmen mehr wie
erklären sie das daher im fußballstadion
es hat draußen in dem sinne und werden
die fallzahlen wirklich hoch wären würde
auch die masken pflicht wieder im
fußballstadium kommen können das müssten
die länder dann machen somit ist es
nicht so dass also grundsätzlich also
auch draußen keine masken mehr getragen
werden müssen sondern das kann jederzeit
kommen wenn die fahrzeuge hoch sind aber
wir müssen natürlich die älteren
menschen in den pflegeeinrichtungen gut
schützen das ist uns in der
vergangenheit nicht so gut gelungen das
darf nicht mehr vorkommen
daher ist hier vorsicht einfach
angemessen notwendig was viele jetzt
auch nicht verstehen in flugzeugen soll
es jetzt keine masken pflicht mehr geben
in der bahn aber schon warum in ein
flugzeug ist die lüftung viel besser als
in der bahn weil also tatsächlich die
luftzirkulation viel besser ist das ist
auch durch viele studien belegt dazu kam
dass uns quasi die lufthansa mitgeteilt
hatte kann es gar nicht mehr also
durchsetzen da sind dann sollte die
ohren die maske nicht also auftragen man
muss das gepäck gesucht werden der flug
kann nicht starten also mann saß ich da
einfach nicht mehr in der lage und von
daher ist das erst einmal ausgesetzt
werden die fallzahlen stark steigen
würden würden wir das allerdings als
bundesregierung wieder verpflichtend
machen dann müsste im flugzeug sogar die
ffb zwei maske getragen gerade bei der
fehlenden masken pflicht jetzt oder das
ist keine masken pflicht mehr gibt in
flugzeugen hört man dass sich die fdp
durchgesetzt hat das ist ein großes
geschachere war also spielt ja auch der
frieden in der koalition eine rolle bei
den entscheidungen oder wird er wirklich
nach pandemischen kriterien es ist nach
pandemischen kriterien entschieden
worden entlang der studientag im großen
und ganzen ist das gekommen was ich mir
schon anfang juli also gewünscht hatte
dass wir also stufenweise vorgehen und
dass wir wieder breit die masken pflicht
bekommen wenn es notwendig ist und sogar
verschärft haben wir jetzt also in
vielen plätzen zum beispiel im
bahnverkehr oder aber auch also in den
kliniken in den praxen sie haben es
gerade gesehen in der pflege haben wir
die masken bricht ja sogar verschärft
ich bin zweimal deshalb habe ich das
gemacht naja weil diese omikron
varianten ansteckender sind das ist
wissenschaftlich also sicher weil das
ist zwar eine variante werden mann
erkrankt er kann man oft nicht so schwer
aber sie ist noch ansteckender daher
machen bessere masken mehr sind werden
schon nass wird und das ist typisch eine
wissenschaftliche ableitung das ist
gelungen wir haben sehr viel also
umgesetzt was viele insbesondere
fdp-wähler beispielsweise für vollkommen
abhängigkeiten masken sind sie dass eine
impfung das andere die ersten omikron
booster impfstoffe sollen jetzt ende
dieser woche heute heute naja impft
werden es gibt auch noch keine
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
wann kommt die impfkommission arbeitet
daran also die kommission hat er jetzt
so eine subgruppe gegründet die
sogenannte power co die sich also mit
pandemie impfungen beschäftigt da bin
ich ab jetzt auch gast wir hatten unser
erstes hessen bereits also in dieser
woche und daher wird also an
empfehlungen gearbeitet die stiko ist da
mit dieser subgruppe unterwegs und würde
empfehlungen abgeben aber auch jetzt ist
natürlich klar die geltenden regeln
sagen ja was mit dem jeweils
zugelassenen impfstoffen die
impfempfehlungen gelten das heißt jetzt
gilt die stiko empfiehlt ja zum beispiel
die zweite booster impfung für die über
60 jährigen das gilt auch für die neue
neben stoffe ab heute können eingesetzt
werden das sind sehr gute impfstoffe
schützen deutlich besser gegen omikron
varianten mit denen wir derzeit ringen
und dann kommt ende des monats
wahrscheinlich oder ein bisschen später
ein weiterer impfstoff gegen die
dominierende omikron variante b a 5 ist
ja angepasst wie unterscheiden sich die
beiden impfstoffe und wer sollte welchen
impfstoff nehmen beide sind gleich gut
also der jetzt so angebotene bivalenten
impfstoff
der schützt gegen die br 1 variante die
wir derzeit nicht mehr haben aber auch
gegen die b a 5 variante die wir haben
hat aber den zusätzlichen vorteil wir
sehen derzeit eine neue variante die wir
bekommen könnten pa 275 da würde sogar
dieser baa1 impfstoff den wir jetzt
gerade ab heute nutzen etwas besser
sogar schützen wahrscheinlich somit also
die einfache antwort ist das würde man
muss die dinge ja einfach erklären nicht
kompliziert beide impfstoffe sind für
den herbst ausgezeichnet geeignet wir
wissen ja nicht was der herbst bringt
was der winter bringt wenn aber die
zahlen auf den intensivstationen nicht
massiv nach oben gehen wäre dann nicht
auch die zeit für weniger regeln und
mehr eigenverantwortung
das kennt man ja auch also die regeln
sind ja jetzt ermöglichen das heißt was
wird passieren wenn es so wäre dass die
fallzahlen nicht ansteigen nicht stark
ansteigen dann würden viele der regeln
die wir jetzt gerade besprochen haben
nicht zum tragen kommen ich selbst werde
immer kritisiert also wenn ich sage wir
müssen auf das schlimmste vorbereitet
sein aber denken sie sich mal in meine
lage hinein wenn ich nicht vor davor
warnen würde das ist auch so kommen kann
das sage ich auch alle vieler
wissenschaftler und wäre nicht
vorbereitet es wäre nicht akzeptabel
dass sie im dritten herbstakademie so
reingehen wie letzten herbst das können
wir uns nicht leisten daher muss ich
warnen muss aber besser vorbereitet sein
als wir sie war ich glaube wir waren
noch nie so gut vorbereitet für einen
herbstlich dieses mal wir haben das im
griff das ist meine persönliche
überzeugung auch wenn es schwerer kommen
sollte und das ist das wofür wir
gearbeitet haben den ganzen sommer sie
müssen heute noch in den bundestag
präsentieren dort ihren haushalt heute
digitalisierung ist ein großes thema in
der gesundheitspolitik da fehlt auch
nicht viel ist wie wollen sie dann
sicherstellen dass deutschland da ja auf
die schiene kommt in sachen dicker
fehler gemacht also zum einen wenn wir
einen prozess gestattete in sogenannten
partizipativen prozess der
digitalisierung wo wir mit den
allerersten mit pflege also
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftlern
patienten so zusammenkommen hatte
gestern große veranstaltung noch mal zu
wo wir noch mal also die einen neustart
bei der digitalisierung machen wir haben
noch viele technische gelöst bisher ich
glaube keine anwendung und da habe ich
mache ich dann bringe ich einen schub
zum tragen das elektronische rezept
haben wir letzte woche also scharf
gestellt elektronische
arbeitsunfähigkeit 23 millionen mal
genutzt bis august die elektronische
patientenakte als opt out lösung das
heißt jeder ist erstmal vorgesehen soll
im nächsten jahr kommen die
krankenhäuser werden jetzt digitalisiert
also für die pandemie kulturell
kontrolle in diesem herbst im panamera
wir haben da unfassbar viel also auf den
weg gebracht das geht oft unter weil
also andere themen dominieren aber offen
gesagt wir haben in diesem jahr in der
digitalisierung an schwerpunkt gesetzt
und bin da auch mit anderen ländern in
kontakt trat sie jetzt also samstag mit
experten nach israel wo das besonders
weit fortgeschritten ist und wird nicht
dort also ein paar tage nur der
digitalisierung was können wir von den
besten lernen was können wir von israel
lernen viele baustellen unter anderem
der haushalt heute im bundestag und vor
allem auch das infektionsschutzgesetz
dass der bundestag heute beschließen
carter war von der spd der
bundesgesundheitsminister vielen dank
ich danke ihnen dank